bonsoir bienvenue dans vos conversations
mon invitait ce soir est un homme libre
allié d'Emmanuel Macron est néanmoins
empêcheur de ma chrononiser en rond le
président du MoDem François Bayrou on
sait qu'il a l'oreille d'Emmanuel Macron
mais est-il entendu à mes côtés pour
discuter avec François Bayrou les
éditorialistes Tonica et Christophe
Barbier on sera ensuite rejoint par le
communicant Gaspard gangster et le chef
Bruno vergius c'est parti
[Musique]
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous ce soir à
mes côtés Nicolas dognac
depuis septembre vous plaidez pour
davantage de pédagogie autour de cette
réforme des retraites mais maintenant on
est dans une séquence où la pédagogie
fonctionne à plein régime mais on
constate que plus le gouvernement voilà
c'est ça parce que on peut dire ça
est-ce que vous parlez de cette séquence
de Franck Riester donc le ministre des
Relations avec le Parlement qui était
hier sur Public Sénat alors on va
l'écouter lui on va écouter la façon
dont Elisabeth borne a tenté cet
après-midi à l'Assemblée nationale de
rectifier le tiroir que quand la
pédagogie tourne à l'envers c'est
presque pire
les femmes pour pouvoir
atteindre leur durée de cotisation
utilise et c'est bien légitime et on le
conforte dans cette réforme utilise
notamment des trimestres valider par
enfant si vous reportez l'âge légal
elles sont évidemment un peu pénalisés
je ne peux pas laisser dire que notre
projet ne protégerait pas les femmes
au contraire
l'augmentation moyenne des petites
pensions sera deux fois plus élevée pour
elle que pour les hommes nous avons
veillé à protéger les plus fragiles les
plus modestes y compris les femmes
comment faire pour que le gouvernement
explique mieux François Bayrou et je le
dis avec un peu de féminisme n'est-ce
pas
bon vous voyez bien
j'ai participé à ce débat depuis le
début
en essayant ou en demandant que on met
entre les mains des citoyens de
l'opinion publique
tous les éléments pour que chacun puisse
se forger une opinion parce que ma
conviction c'est que la démocratie c'est
ça la plupart des gens croient que la
démocratie ça consiste seulement à élire
des responsables
et puis
moi je pense au contraire
pas au contraire je pense
au surplus que ça consiste à considérer
les citoyens comme des partenaires de la
décision comme correspondables de la
décision
et ça porte sur plusieurs sujets le
premier sujet le plus important de tous
c'est que on nous dit que les systèmes
de retraite est équilibré et même
excédentaire et que c'est comment je
peux dire ça une
présentation
au minimum biaisé une présentation vous
n'êtes pas beaucoup François
bayroula dans la séquence parce que
quand on est quand même le patron du
corps qui vient devant les micros pour
dire ah ben non en fait tout va bien
vous dites tout à fait ce que je pense
je pense qu'il y a une légèreté de la
part d'un certain nombre de responsables
à s'exprimer sur une situation qu'il
connaisse parfaitement mais sur laquelle
ils ne disent pas la vérité alors moi je
vais vous donner des chiffres simples
il y a un sondage BVA pour RTL qui a été
publié aujourd'hui et les Français
reconnaissent à 64% ne pas s'être
renseignés précisément sur le contenu de
la 64 ça veut dire quoi ce gouvernement
n'est plus audible ça n'est pas
seulement la responsabilité des Français
c'est la responsabilité des gouvernants
des parlementaires
c'est la responsabilité
collective de ceux qui ont la charge du
pays mais parmi ceux qui ont la charge
du pays pour moi il y a les citoyens
qu'il faut considérer comme des
partenaires pour moi la démocratie c'est
une société de co-responsabilité
générale que vous soyez dans
l'opposition ou dans la majorité vous
êtes co-responsable mais que vous soyez
syndicaliste ou politique vous êtes
co-responsable et si vous êtes des
moyens il souscrit donc je pense que non
seulement il souscrit mais je pense que
c'est chez lui une réflexion
qui vient de loin vous savez il a fait
il a suscité le ce qu'on appelle le CNR
le Conseil national de la refondation
pour ça avec l'idée
alors je ne dis pas que ça soit parfait
je ne dis pas qu'on y arrive c'est un
effort constant et qui en France et pas
un effort fréquent mais pour moi il est
essentiel alors je vous donne les
chiffres sur les retraites pour voir ce
si c'est vrai ou pas et ces chiffres
sont je les ai publiés dans un rapport
du plan ils n'ont teinté contesté par
personne vous n'avez pas entendu une
seule contestation je donne les chiffres
les pensions en France il faut chaque
année il fallait au niveau de l'an
dernier verset
345 milliards pour payer les pensions et
sur ces 345 milliards
en assure
143 milliards c'est-à-dire plus de 40 %.
alors qu'il emploie que que 20% des
salariés comme fonctionnaires ou
contractuel l'État les collectivités
locales les hôpitaux et vous voyez bien
qu'il y a une disparité incroyable alors
je vous donne les chiffres encore une
fois précis
dans ces 143 milliards
les cotisations patronales que l'État
devrait comme tout comme tout patron ça
représente 25 milliards
les obligations que l'État créé au
caisse de retraite par exemple les
années dont on a parlé les années
davantage familiaux ou bien l'allègement
des charges pour les petits salaires
ça représente 90 milliards
restent 30 milliards qui sont pas autre
chose que la subvention de l'État pour
équilibrer les régimes de retraite pas
seulement les régimes spéciaux les
régimes spéciaux c'est 7 ou 8 milliards
mais pour équilibrer les régimes de
retraite or le corps a choisi
de dire
c'est 30 milliards de déficits dont je
vous dirai un mot dans une minute il
compte pas on ne les prend pas en compte
nous n'allons parler que des déficits
possibles dans l'avenir
mais possible ou certains dans l'avenir
et c'est ainsi qu'on ramène les déficits
à des chiffres de genre 10 12 15
milliards et accumulé tous les ans ça
fait de très grosses sommes mais enfin
on ne peut pas
ignorer cette situation
insupportable que nous faisons payer nos
retraites par des subventions d'État qui
ne sont pas autre chose que de la dette
François
là il faut il faut s'arrêter
bien mais quand même quelques questions
parfois le votre nature généreuse
ressort donc voilà mais j'ai quand même
quelques questions à vous poser oui vous
avez aussi quelques natures généreuses
et donc
arrêtons-nous une seconde ça veut dire
que nous faisons payer les pensions de
retraite par les générations qui
viennent
nous faisons payer les pensions des
retraités d'aujourd'hui
par les salariés de demain qui auront
aussi à payer les retraites
Barbier a parfaitement raison tout ceci
fait une accumulation 30 milliards
et parfois quand je dis ça ça crée des
éclairs d'incompréhension ou
d'interrogations dans le regard de ceux
à qui je parle 30 milliards c'est 30 000
millions d'euros tous les ans 30
000 millions d'euros tous les ans
combien de lycées
engagée
c'est un commensurable
c'est 30 milliards là le corps dit je
n'en tiens pas compte
ou plus exactement je considère qu'ils
devront être toujours versés que c'est
une règle une convention comme ils
disent la société a convenu qu'elle
verserait ça et pour moi c'est un très
grave souci démocratique et si les
Français avaient tu connaissances de ces
chiffres
non pas connaissance de ces chiffres
vous l'avez dit vous-même
il y avait pas de problème il a dit les
dépenses ni des rat pas évidemment il y
a déjà 30 milliards garantis chaque
année ça dérape plus hein ça dérape plus
par rapport aux prévisions exactement
vous qui connaissez bien si vous voulez
les depuis longtemps les rapports de
force politique les cristallisation
politique et sociales là on est quand
même dans un moment où il y a un mauvais
qui souffle sur cette réforme et sur le
gouvernement qui la porte
je dirais pas un vent mauvais il y a il
y a le mécanisme habituel de la
mobilisation
quand un projet qui est en effet
troublant pour les carrières
personnelles de de chacun des Français
mais qui surtout
n'est pas relié dans dans le débat
public
à cette
impossibilité ou quelque chose
d'insupportable dans le rapport entre
les générations et si on le faisait je
suis persuadé que beaucoup de Français
diraient bon au bout du compte il faut
il faut bien faire quelque chose ça
c'est la première question mais j'avais
dit qu'il y avait deux sujets de
préoccupation j'ai dit aussi que ce
texte était améliorable parce que il y a
forcément des zones d'incertitude des
zones
d'ombres dans la compréhension immédiate
de cette réforme et on a vu avec les
femmes avec la question des retraites
des femmes illustration Emmanuel Macron
qui au fond avait à considérer qu'il a
fait la concession suprême la concession
symbolique suprême sur le recul de des
65 ans c'est 65 à 64 ans il l'a fait
avant même que la rue ne se manifeste
est-ce que c'était pas une concession
faite trop tôt tactiquement là
franchement vous êtes injuste parce que
si on lui faisait ce reproche oui son
idée non mais faites trop tôt par
rapport
était d'entrer dans le débat avec 65 ans
et pour passer un accord tactique avec
les républicains est-ce que ça s'était
habile dans la mesure où il ensuite il
fallait il se privait de marge de
manœuvre pour pour donner quelque chose
à la rue tout le monde lui a conseillé
ça et un bon conseil et vous vous êtes
genre à pouvoir dire que tout le monde
l'a conseillé mais que c'était pas la
bonne idée
je pense qu'il faut pas vivre cette
réforme ou ce débat avec en tête la
question de l'habileté
ça compte aussi quand même pour faire
passer des réformes l'essentiel c'est la
question de la sincérité et de
l'authenticité
d'authenticité vous savez parfaitement
François Malbrouck Emmanuel Macron il
avait une réforme des retraites qui lui
tenait au coeur et à l'esprit c'était la
réforme universelle par point il la
portée en 2016 en 2017-2018 2019
c'est très fort mais les vivantes elle a
été votée juste avant la covid elle est
dans le tuyau législatif pourquoi on la
reprend pas et bien
Christophe Barbier je trouve que que
vous avez des suggestions très
intéressantes mais la vérité c'est que
nous ne sommes plus dans dans cette dans
cet acte là le le la Révolution elle
était là le cadre spatio-temporel comme
le philosophe que vous êtes
dirait le cadre spatio-temporel n'est
plus celui-là on a changé de cadre donc
c'est trop tard
c'est jamais trop tard mais c'est trop
tard pour la période pour laquelle nous
sommes je suis absolument persuadé que
la question des retraites reviendra
forcément parce que un pays ne peut pas
accepter cette injustice qui consiste à
charger les plus jeunes
pour payer au jour le jour les pensions
des plus âgées c'est impossible c'est
inacceptable dans nos propres familles
si nous regardons chacun d'entre nous
nous avons tous dans nos familles des
enfants des neveux des mais on ne peut
pas accepter ça et donc le je trouve que
que
forcément se débalade devrait être
ouvert
de voir qu'Emmanuel Macron aujourd'hui
se retrouve presque seul contre tous à
porter une réforme qui n'est même pas
celle à laquelle il croyait je pense que
si vous étiez dans dans l'intimité d'une
conversation avec lui
je pense qu'il serait peut-être au fond
de lui-même y a-t-il une partie de ça la
réforme qui voulait là il est obligé
d'aller jusqu'au bout la réforme qu'il
voulait était un plus ambitieuse de plus
juste
et toi mieux adaptés au futur et alors
il se trouve que le après les
difficultés rencontrées dans la première
période il a été décidé
collectivement qu'on allait faire une
réforme moins ambitieuse
d'Édouard Philippe
et donc je trouve oui je trouve que que
nous sommes dans une situation qui exige
de la responsabilité un sentiment
d'urgence
et que la
la réforme qui aurait permis l'équilibre
durable
adapté en temps réel on en a un exemple
parfait sous les yeux comme vous savez
c'est les retraites du privé du secteur
privé agirco
les retraits du secteur privé elles sont
entre les mains des partenaires sociaux
c'est eux qui en ont la responsabilité
et ils ont pris toutes les décisions
nécessaires pour qu'elles soient
équilibrée les sacrifices demandés les
ont fait et cette ce régime déprivé du
privé aujourd'hui il est équilibré et il
est il a dans l'épaisseur du trait des
déficits mais qui sont
infiniment moins importants que les
déficits que nous observons dans
l'ensemble du système de retraite et
dans le secteur public on se retrouve
dans une situation où c'est comme c'est
comme la cuvette de Diane bien fou si
vous voulez manuel Macron il a choisi
son terrain il a Il a décrété que
c'était la mère de toutes ces réformes
que son quinquennat
la deuxième quinquennat devait se juger
à l'aune de se réformisme là sur les
retraites mais attendez vous souvenez
bien de fou qu'est-ce qui se passe et
bien vous donner vous tous vos ennemis
tous vos opposants non plus qu'à tirer
des requêtes sur vous et c'est ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui oui
là pour l'instant nous sommes dans le
schéma le plus classique non un peu plus
que le classique quand même plus
classique exactement le plus classique
on propose une réforme qui ne règle pas
tous les problèmes moins sans faut qui
est améliorable et évidemment ça suscite
une levée de bouclier importante on a
déjà vécu ça alors c'est classique mais
il faut quand même à chaque fois trouver
un moyen d'en sortir il peut y avoir
l'endurance et puis on pèse sur
l'épuisement du conflit ça peut ne pas
être le cas on peut si j'ose dire
envoyer les parachutistes de surnb fou
non pas ceux du général Bigard mais ceux
du général Bayrou est-ce que le modem au
Parlement pourra apporter des solutions
acceptables par la majorité le reste
grande majorité pour sortir par le haut
de ce moment de tension mettre plus de
justice dans le projet en changeant un
peu les règles de financement je pense
au ballon d'essai que vous avez lancé
sur petite taxe sur les entreprises
d'autres parlent des super profits
encore une fois mais également
l'allongement du temps de travail la
semaine des 35 heures est-ce que vous
allez aller au bout ou est-ce que ce
restera une boîte à outils a répondu
niet miette pour l'instant
il y a deux phases dans cette question
il y a le débat parlementaire classique
dans lequel nous allons entrer peut-être
le débat parlementaire classique va
permettre d'avoir un vrai débat
je l'espère
je n'en suis pas sûr mais je ne suis pas
sûr du contraire il y a quelques jours
encore on annonçait que les oppositions
allaient déposer des dizaines de
milliers d'amendements qui est une
manière d'interdire le débat il semble
on entend une petite musique vous
l'entendez aussi qui disent que
finalement c'est pas comme ça que ça va
se passer donc on va peut-être avoir un
vrai débat on va pouvoir répondre à
toutes ces questions et notamment aux
questions de justice les carrières
longues les métiers pénibles le
la situation particulière des femmes qui
en raison de leur vie de famille ont des
vies professionnelles hachées comme on
dit
peut-être on va pouvoir avancer puis il
y a le Sénat
parce que derrière la complémentarité
des deux assemblées le Sénat étant moins
comment je peux dire moi sous pression
des des groupes de pression et des
choses explosives il y a pas
d'opposition de gauche radicale qui
tiennent voilà
euphémistique comme on dit se dire la
même chose que vous et donc le
peut-être on va pouvoir avancer et puis
peut-être le Parlement ayant tranché la
solution s'imposera-t-elle dans le pays
vous voyez bien que que c'est un moment
d'hésitation de bascule c'est plus que
ça pardon François Bayrou j'ai
l'impression que vous vous battez contre
un imaginaire qui est plus fort que vous
l'imaginaire que la retraite c'est
devenu au fond ce lieu ce moment de vie
que le travail actuel n'offre plus et
que face à ça vous avez pas un récit qui
peut percuter et que
les Français prennent connaissance du
texte qu'il aurait proposé vous avez vu
l'évolution elle est toujours plus
négative donc je vois pas où est le
récit qui pourrait l'emporter d'abord ça
encore c'est classique
j'ai dit très souvent que dans les
débats politiques qui implique le pays
la vague du nom va plus vite va plus
vite et va plus haut que la vague du oui
de la sentiment donc ça c'est absolument
classique mais vous avez dit quelque
chose Nicolas Domenach de très très
important et de très très juste ce qui
est en question dans cette affaire c'est
le regard qu'on porte sur le travail
et sur l'organisation des carrières
et sur le fait que
en réalité
la retraite apparaît comme une issue
pour ceux qui n'en peuvent plus de la
manière dont leur travail est organisé
et en France on a cultivé ça parce que
l'imaginaire construit autour de la
retraite à 60 ans qui était
un des sujets de l'élection de François
Mitterrand en 1981 cette imaginaire là
a présenté le 60 ans comme honnage dans
lequel on changeait de vie on allait
trouver et il y a des gens pour qui
c'est absolument vital parce que il y a
des épuisements personnels
psychologiques
physiologique et en même temps il y a
des gens qui prolongeraient bien
simplement une partie de ces gens qui
prolongeraient bien ils n'ont pas
d'emploi parce que dans l'esprit des
Ressources Humaines des entreprises il y
a aussi l'idée que à partir de 60 ans et
elle va vers une pentecinante ce qui
n'est pas absolument pour vous
c'est ce à quoi réfléchit le
gouvernement mais ils ont décidé que ce
serait pas coercitif que ce serait au
fond que ça allait être incitatif mais
que n'y aurait pas de contraintes qui
s'exercerait sur les patrons
petite contrainte Françoise
il faut juste attendre il faut juste
sortir l'index mais même si l'index
était épouvantable
il y a pas de
représailles je vais vous dire que je
crois
c'est que c'est un des sujets sur
lesquels le mouvement de l'âge légal
apporte une réponse collective parce que
si dans la tête des entreprises et des
salariés eux-mêmes il y a l'idée que bon
allez au maximum c'est 60 62 mais si on
vous dit
le signal est plutôt à 63 64 et 65 pour
ceux qui veulent pour ceux qui peuvent
et 66 ça améliorera leur pension à ce
moment là quelque chose se passe qui
fait que au lieu d'être mis au rencard
vous redevenez employable à partir de
ces âges-là vous redevenez membre de la
vie active c'est d'ailleurs ce qui se
passe dans tous les autres pays
européens qui nous entourent mais est-ce
qu'on ne peut pas stimuler ce
comportement en effet que le marché peut
engendrer par une petite contrainte vous
êtes dans un secteur par exemple vous
avez une entreprise de peinture on
regarde la moyenne d'âge des des seniors
la moyenne d'employabilité des seigneurs
dans votre secteur si vous êtes en
dessous on vous met une petite pénalité
fiscale si vous êtes au dessus que vous
gardiez mieux vos donc d'incitation une
incitation ben vous devriez faire de la
politique gère cet amendement à
l'Assemblée vous avez quelques rôles
bien suggestion Barbier très bien et
alors ce qui peut pas y en avoir
d'autres j'ai employé un gros mot pour
la macronie pour certains d'entre eux
pour Bruno Le Maire me dire il y a quand
même eu des hyper profits il y a quand
même des retraités beaucoup plus riches
que des salariés il y a quand même de
fonds de l'injustice qui est qui rôde
qui plus qui rôde qui s'est incrusté un
sentiment d'injustice en tout cas il y a
aucune mesure qui pourrait vous-même
vous aviez proposé des mesures à
certains moments qui ont été retoqués
c'est trop là aussi c'est trop tard
d'abord vous aussi vous devriez faire de
la politique que la domenaque et si vous
cherchez où vous pourrez vous apporter
une réponse non le
la question de la justice
de la perception de la réforme comme
juste et la clé de l'acceptation de la
réforme et c'est la raison pour laquelle
vous avez raison de le dire notre groupe
à l'Assemblée nationale a proposé
plusieurs idées
par exemple qui n'ont pas été toute
seule
je sais depuis longtemps
qu'avant d'être majoritaire il faut être
binôme elle a dit qu'il y avait beaucoup
de créativité au modem il a dit avec
beaucoup d'ironie je suis très fier que
en effet que la créativité soit un
élément d'identité du du parti politique
et du courant
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans
la tête de ce qui réfléchissent à ces
questions dans la tête il y a on demande
tous les efforts au travail
participation cotisation travaillait
plus longtemps et on ne demande aucun
effort à d'autres aspects par exemple
l'imposition du capital en France
mes amis ont constamment cette réalité à
l'esprit l'imposition du capital en
France et quand même beaucoup plus
avantageuse les revenus du capital que
les revenus du travail et ils avaient
pensé en effet de mettre une
participation c'est Jean-Paul battayi
qui avait proposé ça comme vous savez ça
fait l'actualité
je suis persuadé que
maintenant ou plus tard cette question
de justice
dans l'équilibre social du pays sera une
question dominante pregnante comme on
dit 73% des Français c'est le BVA
d'aujourd'hui considère que la réforme
est injuste
encore une fois c'est c'est un effort de
de définition et de construction de la
politique que nous voulons mener alors
vous dites vous êtes minoritaire oui
largement oui et puis c'est pas c'est
pas grave c'est pas déshonorant
je peux pas dire ça j'aime les deux
gourmandise quand même dans vos yeux je
ne déteste pas le combat sur des sur des
éléments très très
fondée très solide et je pense lorsque
oui nous avancerons dans ce sens là et
bien on vous retrouve dans quelques
instants François Bayrou
mère Christophe Barbier
pour la suite de cette conversation et
on sera rejoint par le communique en gaz
par gangster et le chef Bruno à tout de
suite
[Musique]
la présence est l'heure de poursuivre
notre conversation avec François Bayrou
Nicolas Domenach et restez avec moi et
on accueille le communique en gaz par
cancer et le chef Bruno versus le soir
les deux à Nicolas
je vous sens les amis du plateau savent
que j'ai une pièce de théâtre dans la
tête et je me demande si elle se joue
pas
véritablement dans notre vie politique
la pièce de théâtre c'est celle de
Ionesco Le roi se meurt le roi se meurt
et il commando au garde d'arrêter cet
homme les gardes s'arrêtent même enfin
le pouvoir devient complètement
évanescent donc je me demande si on
n'est pas en train de vivre de façon
impalpable pour l'instant mais ça sera
plus en plus concret dire le fait que le
Président de la République qui ne peut
pas se représenter au fond ne commande
plus vraiment ou comme avant ou comme il
pourrait donc je voulais avoir votre
sentiment je ne crois rien de tout ça
en aucune manière et ça fait longtemps
que ça se raconte je signale que de se
raconter aussi pendant le premier
quinquennat
on disait mais tout ça se décompose et
ça n'était pas vrai c'est les temps qui
se décomposent ce qu'on est en train de
vivre c'est cette une
[Musique]
un effacement ou en tout cas une
fragilisation
de la plupart des liens qui font une
société et ceci dans tous les pays du
monde
même sous les régimes autoritaires c'est
dire que
c'est c'est historique ce qu'on est en
train de vivre c'est profond et alors
chaque pays le voit à sa propre
lucarne mais en réalité c'est quelque
chose d'extrêmement vaste et puissant
le les pouvoirs partout ont cette
difficulté l'idée le temps où les
pouvoirs décidaient ou les gens
obéissaient est un temps fini et
heureusement
parce que on peut pas s'affirmer du côté
de la démocratie du côté de d'un
changement des rapports entre le sommet
et la base de la société le prétendu
sommet parce qu'ils veulent pas très
haut et la base de la société on peut
pas prétendre que que ça ne va pas et
accepter cette idée que au fond l'idéal
serait que une décision du haut s'impose
en bas et ça
j'atteste que Emmanuel Macron l'a senti
depuis le premier jour alors
parce qu'il ne pourra pas
constitutionnellement se représenter
dans 4 ans ça le priverait de tout
pouvoir c'est c'est une sornette ça
n'existe pas d'abord parce que s'il peut
pas se représenter dans 4 ans
peut se représenter dans 9 ans oui
donc je veux dire la Constitution ne
l'oblige pas à disparaître du débat
politique
et comme je crois que il est indivisable
d'un des courants principaux de la vie
politique française qu'on a essayé
d'effacer plusieurs fois et qu'on a
réussi à sauver constamment je pense que
que qu'il a qu'il a ce visage cette
puissance et ce rôle et tout le reste et
bien va entraîner des mutations
profondes et qui sont bienvenue je ne
suis pas d'accord avec l'idée qu'on
serait condamné perpétuellement avoir
une vie parlementaire
dérisoire et insultante avec la
perpétuelle explosion de gens qui
s'insultent s'envoient des
sans voile à la figure pas seulement des
épithètes mais quasiment des bagarres
dans lesquels les médias vous avez une
responsabilité parce qu'il suffirait que
vous ne coupiez pas les micro pendant
les débats à l'Assemblée nationale et
qu'on entend réellement ce qui se passe
dans l'hémicycle ben il pourrait pas
continuer ces gens diraient mais rentrer
chez vous
vous pouvez pas donc vous avez une
petite responsabilité mais juste on
revient sur la sur la question
d'Emmanuel Macron et de cette guerre de
succession qui s'est ouverte si tôt sont
sa deuxième élection acté il est obligé
lui-même Emmanuel Macron aujourd'hui de
réfléchir à un successeur quelqu'un qui
va pousser pour être au fond le
l'héritier du macronisme on a tendance
peut-être François Bayrou qui se
représente
le coup d'après et alors parmi ces
héritiers il y a un nom qui revient un
nom qui plaît bien à Emmanuel Macron
c'est celui de l'ancien premier ministre
Jean Castex vous avez entendu ça comme
nous
j'ai deux différences avec vous non
beaucoup plus que ça je pense à deux
différences dans ce débat
première différence je ne crois pas que
les responsables en situation de pouvoir
soit obsédée par leur succession non
mais il pense pour que d'autres ils
pensent ça le sujet alors j'entends bien
toutes les
toutes les manœuvres qui qui vise à
pousser les uns pousser les autres pour
effacer les autres la vie ce n'est pas
comme ça que ça se passe
Macron en particulier
en particulier est un darwinien vous
savez Darwin c'est la sélection des
espèces c'est à dire que la vie fait
qu'il y a des gens qui résistent et
d'autre part et l'idée qu'il pourrait
imposer quelqu'un ou faire imposer des
c'est une idée à laquelle je crois il ne
participe pas après qui est auprès de
lui des
tentatives de cet ordre c'est possible
mais c'est pas comme ça la vie jamais
bien sûr qu'un jamais une personnalité
capable d'être candidate à l'élection
présidentielle n'est suscité par des
mouvements de cet ordre jamais
c'est
si le type au sens féminin ou masculin a
en lui la rage l'envie la la certitude
intérieure que l'essentiel se joue là et
que son destin est d'être là à ce
moment-là il fait son chemin et personne
ne fait le chemin à la place de
quelqu'un d'autre qui en octobre dernier
déjà et dernièrement plus tard que le 15
janvier ne cache pas sa disponibilité
regardez on l'écoute
je ferai tout ce que je peux dans toutes
les échéances donc y compris
toujours été prêt j'ai déjà été candidat
trois fois que ce que vous me racontez
est-ce que c'est pour moi à titre
personnel une obsession de chaque matin
non
est-ce que cela dit c'est une engagement
écartée non s'il y a un seul responsable
politique qui ne pense pas à l'élection
majeure ce qui est on se demande ce
qu'il fait dans ce dans cet engagement
dans ce jeu c'est là comme vous savez
bien que tout se joue
qu'est-ce que vous pensez il est pas mal
c'était la question qu'il a tout dit
sans blague
tout le monde fait semblant des
quartiers les yeux sur quelque chose que
tout le monde a en tête le la vie
politique française elle tourne et c'est
heureux et ça vous intéresse vous direz
pourquoi ah oui elle tourne autour de
l'élection présidentielle
la
chance que nous avons c'est que le
général de Gaulle a donné cet instrument
autrement c'est les manœuvres
parlementaires
et quand de Gaulle a créé sa
constitution et qu'il l'a annoncé
à l'avance à Bayeux il a dit nous allons
arracher le pouvoir exécutif au manœuvre
parlementaire et il a raison il y a
besoin de ce lien direct
j'allais dire charnel entre les citoyens
et celui à qui il confie la
responsabilité la plus importante et ça
fait que il y a pas de personnalité
médiocre
très peu il y a
[Rires]
quoi vous regardez
un clin d'œil
on devait penser au même au pluriel oui
non il y a des personnalités dont on
n'est pas sûr que on les aurait choisi
soi-même mais en tout cas c'est jamais
des débats médiocres jamais et ce sont
des débats qui sont orientés par des
questions profondes de la société la
question de la justice et une question
profonde et la question de la confiance
est une question profonde j'appa si mal
juste il y a une plaisanterie qui court
dans Paris je voulais savoir si elle
vous fait rire ou pas qui dit Bruno Le
Maire ne pourra pas se présenter à
l'élection présidentielle parce qu'il a
déjà fait demanda on a
on dit que c'est Gérald de chez Darmanin
ça vous fait quand même oui
je suis pas absolument certain de te
saisir tout l'humour de cette affaire
parce que s'il y a une chose dont je
sois certain moi c'est que le Président
de la République c'est Emmanuel Macron
et il laisse pas sa partage si je puis
m'exprimer en terme familiaux familier
et familiaux et il occupe
sans que ce soit mis en doute par qui
que ce soit il
occupe pleinement la responsabilité que
cette fonction impose pour
pour le présent et pour l'avenir et il a
bien raison de le faire
la musique n'est-ce pas qu'on entend à
l'Assemblée nationale celle dont
François Bayrou nous reproche n'est-ce
pas à nous journaliste de ne pas laisser
le bruit arriver jusqu'aux oreilles des
Français alors quand même quand même il
y a quand même des petits bruits
une lettre particulièrement puérile
grandissez un peu faire de la petite
politique de la petite poloche se servir
du cercueil d'une gamine de 12 ans comme
on se sert d'un marchepied c'est une
honte monsieur le député tu vas la faire
mais
[Applaudissements]
je m'étonne un tout petit peu
honnêtement du niveau de tension que je
n'ai jamais vu en 12 ans de Parlement
j'ai honte pour vous on découvre
défendez aujourd'hui on monte de voir
que vous avez renié l'ensemble de vos
projets les procès en trahison je suis
immunisé surtout quand ils viennent par
ceux qui ont vendu la sociale démocratie
à l'extrême gauche pour sauver leur
siège
oui on a voulu aborder ce sujet d'abord
pour poser une première question
rebondissant sur ce disait Olivier Véran
à l'instant vous avez de l'expérience
vous avez pas vécu toutes les
républiques bien évidemment et tout
depuis 12 ans
alors ce sont les fonctionné dans la
pratique et dans l'histoire est-ce que
c'est si nouveau que ça finalement ce
c'est ces insultes ce clash
ce degré de tension est accentué par le
fait qu'il y a pas de majorité
probablement et donc comme il n'y a pas
de majorité paradoxalement le rôle du
Parlement devrait être plus
conséquent plus importants plus lourd
plus respecté ce que c'est là que les
consensus devraient se nouer que les
débats devraient avoir lieu et le et la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes qui
est choquante c'est que alors qu'il
devait être plus lourd il est plus léger
tombant dans la dérision tombant dans
l'insulte il se comporterait pas comme
ça les gens
les députés si les gens les voyaient
probablement donc
oui c'est nouveau de ce point de vue là
et alors comment est-ce qu'on fait alors
vous avez parlé excusez-moi de vous
couper mais est-ce que vous avez dit
tout à l'heure que les médias avaient
une responsabilité c'est possible alors
je veux dire mais du coup j'ai bien
compris j'ai bien compris et de l'autre
de l'autre côté si on se met du côté des
politiques je crois que nous sommes
plusieurs auto la table tout je pense
être apôtre de la rationalité du débat
public d'une forme d'unité comment
est-ce qu'on peut faire pour la rétablir
est-ce que c'est un vieux ou est-ce que
c'est déjà une réflexion de vieux con
que je
[Rires]
vous auriez pu ça m'aurait pas gêné donc
c'est
moi je pense que ça va changer alors
vous direz que je suis optimiste ou
idéaliste c'est vrai allons-y mais je
pense que ça va changer je pense que
le que la situation est-elle qu'ils ne
vont pas ce il collectif pouvoir
continuer comme ça
qui vont bien être obligés de se
rapprocher de ce que l'histoire
l'événement
leur impose ou exige 2
que ça va bouger simplement nous vivons
une nouvelle époque avec les règles de
l'ancienne et alors le débat
parlementaire est aussi dérisoire qu'il
a souvent été mais normalement
il devrait se mettre peu à peu à la
hauteur du moment à la hauteur de
l'événement peut-être pour retrouver la
profondeur est-ce qu'on peut parler de
littérature
d'une autre personnalité qui qui aime
beaucoup les livres autant que vous je
crois ou en tout cas
et j'aime bien cette expression les
livres qui vous travaillent parce que
vous les lisez vous les trouvez
intelligents très bien et puis dans la
durée il produit quelque chose ils ont
planté une graine où ils ont ils ont
brillé quelque chose et vous y pensez ça
vous travaille et ça vous transforme et
les livres vous transformez ils peuvent
vous transformer comme ça boum sur le
moment justement foudre et puis parfois
c'est dans la durée dans la durée alors
c'était en juillet 2017 il venait
d'arriver à Matignon et de leur Philippe
vous êtes agrégés de lettres l'être
classique même je crois vous avez la
suffit de dire
vous savez le c'est une plaisanterie
entre nous parce que pour les autres il
faut mettre des adjectifs
pour ceux qui ne sont qui n'ont pas le
droit à la belle et grande agrégation
vous vous souvenez certainement que sur
la photo de officielle email Macron
avait fait le choix de mettre trois
livres un livre de Gide si je me
souviens bien du général de Gaulle et de
Stendhal le rouge et noir vous quel
livre vous auriez choisi personnellement
il faut choisir et peut-être un jour si
on suit
c'est pas une colle répondait avec le
c'est au fond extrêmement juste les
Fables de La Fontaine
parce que il n'y a pas de texte plus
profond sur l'humanité et plus délié
dans l'expression que les Fables de La
Fontaine je mettrai Pascal ah oui
parce qu'il n'y a rien de plus profond
qui était écrit sur les rapports entre
l'homme et l'absolu et l'homme et le
relatif
que
[Musique]
la distinction des ordres c'est-à-dire
ce qui est de l'ordre du spirituel à sa
propre logique ce qui est de l'ordre du
scientifique et sa propre logique et ce
qui est de l'ordre du politique à sa
propre logique et on peut pas faire
commander le politique par la religion
et on peut pas faire commander la
science par la religion
et donc il y a rien de plus important
qui a été écrit que ça sans compter que
les deux infinies si vous ouvrez les
yeux vous n'en guérissez pas ça c'est la
deuxième et un dernier pour la troisième
non j'aurais mis Peggy parce que je suis
parce que Peggy et pour moi
au commencement et
ça accompagnait toute ma vie mais je
crois que c'est une référence que vous
partagez avec abuel Macron vous parlez
de littérature parfois avec le pont de
la République on parle de beaucoup de
choses je ne raconte jamais ce dont on
parle ce qui fait que pour comme ça les
conversations
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
manière non plus pardon pas à nier non
plus
chacun a ses assez goût et c'est cool
les couleurs la chair nous allons parler
avec Bruno verjus politique on aurait pu
imaginer que vous mettiez
Gargantua de François Rabelais parce
qu'on va vous êtes un homme libre vous
êtes le maire de Pau et alors c'est la
ville d'Henri IV évidemment on en
reparlera mais lui il avait à l'égal de
Rabelais finalement une utopiste et
démocratiser un plat on va regarder
la célèbre poule au pot une volaille
farcie mijotée aux petits légumes c'est
le plat emblématique du Béarn fameuse
cette recette c'est le plat paysan par
excellence un plat estampillé Henri iven
ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui la France
profonde il en connaît les traditions il
est tout à fait au fait des souffrances
quand durent le pays à ce moment-là et
on réfléchissant un petit peu il s'est
aperçu que tout le monde avait un petit
peu de volaille quelques légumes et très
facile de rassembler tout ça et de faire
un plat emblématique c'est comme ça que
la poule au pot est née
qui avait consacré cette biographie au
roi libre Henri IV une trentaine
d'années vous confirmez absolument
absolument
lorsque Henri
IV est mort à 17 hommes
avait reçu entre les bras le cadavre de
la France et il lui a rendu la vie
parce que les guerres de religion avait
fait que le pays lui-même avait disparu
le lien entre les gens avaient disparu
au Bénin
envahis par par ce cancer de la division
et ça entraînait des misères formidables
et il a eu ce coup de génie avec Sully
parce qu'ils étaient deux il a eu ce
coup de génie de dire
enfin d'offrir emblématiquement
ainsi d'aisance
à tous les foyers
et ce signe des ans c'était la poule au
pot tous les dimanches à tout le monde
peut avoir quand il a un jardin peut
avoir une poule voilà c'est ça
et donc c'est c'est extrêmement profond
Henri IV il avait
beaucoup de défauts et beaucoup de
qualités on le célèbre généralement pour
être le Vert Galant pour ses prouesses
amoureuses il était un amoureux
très contestable à mes yeux très pas
très pas très brillant
et il était en revanche un politique
absolument majeur
ma première éditrice Françoise vernis
que nous sommes plusieurs à avoir connu
ici
quand je lui ai dit que je voulais faire
une biographie d'Henri IV elle m'a dit
Henri IV ça a intéresse personne c'est
une femme j'essaie d'imiter la voix
inimitable de François vernis c'est les
femmes et la poule au pot et bien elle
se elle se trompait beaucoup sur la
profondeur et tous les sondages
quand on fait des sondages sur quel a
été le plus grand souverain français
s'est Henri IV qui sort
et ça veut dire quelque chose de très
profond la réconciliation du pays est-ce
que vous avez vendu 300 000 exemplaires
de ce livre oui comme un Goncourt quoi
il se vend encore et il se vend encore
et est-ce que la poule au poils se vend
encore mais oui
il faut que ça reste comme un plat fait
à la maison on le trouve pas mais par
exemple la ville de Pau est-ce qu'elle a
organisée sa gastronomie autour de la
poule non d'abord on peut organiser
d'abord pourquoi pas
[Musique]
la gastronomie suprême en Béarn c'est la
garbure c'est-à-dire ce potage
particulier cette source particulière
paysanne là
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'elle a de plus que les
autres votre gardien des ingrédients qui
ne sont pas dans les autres
vous avez une petite pointe de céleri
qui ont toutes leurs spécificité le
peuple français c'est les différences
aussi et c'est ça qui est beau dans
cette ce bel événement
oui parce que la garbure donc à droite
c'est championnats et championnat
s'appelle les garbures
de la garbure dans les places simples
justement est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose
qu'on peut citer de particulier j'ai la
garbure c'est un allez une soupe de
légumes paysan oui avec un morceau de de
viande
alors on dit alors en fait soupe de
légumes et d'en regarder dans ces petits
légumes il y a quelque chose de de
formidable dont on oublie souvent le
sens on appelle le haricot maïs qu'il a
évidemment rien à voir avec le maïs
sinon le fait que le maïs va lui servir
de tuteur lui servir de tuteur pour
aller s'enrouler comme ça et faire cette
chose là et puis on dit qu'une garbure
c'est il y a pas de garbure sans
haricots on est d'accord et puis il y a
pas de garbure si ça bout on dit qu'une
garbure ça se met un peu comme ça sur le
coin du feu très longtemps avec le talon
et puis il faut que ça
c'est tranquille quoi
non mais peut-être on peut être candidat
à la présidence de la République parce
que c'est un peu la même chose on garde
les choses au chaud faut pas que ça bout
et puis on attend c'est se briller c'est
vous voyez que vous avez du goût
parallèle voilà
[Rires]
dites-moi alors je sais que vous aimez
vous avez dit tout à l'heure aimer
beaucoup le vin mais je crois que vous
aimez aussi beaucoup le jus de
pamplemousse
un petit peu exotiques finalement
pour le jus de pamplemousse pour le jus
de pamplemousse pour le pamplemousse en
soi c'est parce que dans la vie
je ne
rejette pas les saveurs un peu amères
et là
nous dégustons
de cette phrase François Bayrou
l'amertume oui effectivement c'est
probablement aussi une vertu politique
alors qu'est-ce que vous préférez vous
finalement le Jurançon blanc le Madiran
quels sont vos c'est pas les mêmes vins
c'est pas les mêmes vins mais est-ce
qu'il y en a un qui a besoin
d'apéritif extraordinaire un vin
apéritif oui parce que c'est pas
seulement un vin moelleux c'est un vin
avec un fruit un bouquet une une finesse
et d'ailleurs un des un des vignerons
vient d'être élu vignerons de l'année
qui s'appelle Jean-Marc grussotte et qui
est un type formidable qui est le qui
est le président du Conseil de
développement du Béarn qui est
puissance de la nature et de
l'intelligence il va m'en vouloir de
dire des trucs comme ça mais parce que
on utilise pas trop ce genre de
superlatif mais alors
non pas vraiment mais le Madiran c'est
un vin rouge tannique c'est le Tanat
d'ailleurs le cépage
et donc mais c'est vrai que dans la
journée je ne bois jamais ni d'alcool
bien sûr ni de vin et là j'aime les
agrumes oui toujours j'aime les oranges
on dit que la j'aime les pamplemousses
on dit que les roues légis fait vraiment
la grande concurrence maintenant elle
serait meilleur
[Musique]
c'est quoi cette histoire de compétition
entre les Basques c'est un produit
formidable lire oulégui
mais les bernets disent je préfère le
vin et donc
c'est une très mauvaise plaisanterie que
mes amis basses que me pardonnent
vous savez bien pour être sérieux une
seconde
les progrès en vinification
de tous ces cépages ont été formidables
et les rouler Guy en particulier vous
essayez de vous rattraper là je fais une
plaisanterie stupide
et cette
il y a là un progrès incroyable de la
société du goût et bien voilà on va
finir sur ce progrès incroyable de la
société du goût François Bayrou